hi I'm Derek Dennis I specialize in
repairing and cleaning washing machines
dryers any major appliances
the two main types of washing machines
that I work on are top loaders and front
loaders I'm going to show you how I
clean them
so this top load washer is I would say
between 15 and 17 years old this machine
here hasn't been cleaned I would say
ever since it was purchased the biggest
problem with this the abundance of build
up from you know excessive use of
detergent fabric softener all the
buildup you see that's what causes this
big ring around the top the water
doesn't come up that high that's why you
see the different levels and then you
know the buildup of mold the perfect
ideal circumstance for for mold and
mildew buildup is moisture darkness and
heat so common buildup in these machines
due to overuse of high efficiency
detergent and fabric softener which you
don't need this big build up you're
going to get rust you're going to get
mold mildew
two tablespoons of high efficiency
detergent and no fabric softener will
make your machine last ages longer than
if you're dumping a cup for two of
fabric softener and it doesn't get your
clothes any cleaner I highly recommend
cutting out fabric softener in your
laundry regimen the reason that I'm so
against fabric softener is when you use
fabric softener the reason that it works
is the reason that it's bad so it builds
up like an oily residue because those
enzymes have been trapped inside your
shirt and so that's what causes it to
smell so it's not because of you but
eventually the overuse of high
efficiency detergent and fabric softener
will cause your clothes to smell even if
they're clean
so anytime we maintenance the machine we
want to make sure that we're unplugging
it from a power source and it's good to
cut the water off so generally we start
from top to the bottom the main thing is
removing the tub and cleaning the inner
and outer baskets that's where all of
your smell comes from
with these direct drive machines a lot
of times we have the legs are Rusty and
we'll either scrape them down repaint
them make sure we knock the cobwebs out
all that kind of stuff sometimes we'll
find a little baby stock you never know
we like to use toothbrushes different
different style brushes you have pointy
brushes flat brushes they all have
different jobs but brushes are are very
key that are vital to everything we do
so the brushes really help to get in
there and you know kind of get in the
corners and the crevices to clean all
this mildew and mold out
sometimes the pressure washer doesn't
get inside the balance ring and we have
to some bristles in there and kind of
really put some elbow grease in it my
favorite cleaner is Pine-Sol bleach
Lysol vinegar is more of what I
recommend for people to use through a
washing cycle white distilled vinegar
has acetic compounds that help kill some
bacterias
when we pressure wash first we start the
outside we can get a lot better into the
balance ring a pressure washer the water
Finds Its ways into all the crevices and
it does a much better job at pushing out
all this mold and mildew and detergent
buildup and fabric softener buildup all
the way out of the holes then we can
just rinse it out the inside and we have
pretty much a brand new basket
so the steam cleaning comes usually
comes after the pressure washing just
because we want to get kind of a final
clean the best thing about the steamer
is you know the water comes out at super
high temperature and that helps to
effectively sanitize any of these
crevices or cracks or anything that we
can't just clean with a pressure washer
or bleach
[Music]
so the front load of the cleaning
process it's similar but it's a lot
different in the disassembly and just
the orientation of the basket I can't
remove a basket all the way from a front
loader I can only clean the front half
the old school top loaders are built
like tanks the front loaders are not but
they clean your clothes better they
generally don't need as much cleaning as
a top loader because of the orientation
and the way the water spins inside and
the water actually keeps the tubs
cleaner uh the biggest part of the smell
that we see is from pump building up
lint and debris in there and people not
clean it out and then you stay with the
smell or because people don't wipe out
their their door seal every time they
use the machine they keep the door
closed and then that just builds up a
mildew smell
as long as you keep the door open and
wipe the door seal out and you know run
a washing a washer cleaner tablet
through once a month or so white
distilled vinegar it's not going to
smell I can guarantee it so with this
front loader it actually has a clean out
spot for the lint this is what protects
your pump and this is what keeps helps
keep the smell down internally pull the
door down we can drain the water out of
this little this is a drain hose that
actually pulls whatever water is left
inside the pump and then we take the
filter out clean it out and that's it
it's that simple I recommend doing this
every 30 days at least every six months
and this is going to prevent odor it's
going to keep it's going to keep your
washing machine lasting a whole lot
longer the average lifespan of pretty
much any washer this is two and three
years before the bearings go out you
know just because of and that really
comes from the overuse of of detergent
so when the detergent breaks down that
oil and grease it'll cause the bearings
to get rusted Rusty and then your
washing machine will sound like a jet
plane taking off that's bad bearings
it's really hard to get to if you can't
physically tear these things down and
clean them yourself so the best thing to
do is preventative maintenance two
tablespoons of detergent no fabric
softener at all but if you have to use
it make sure you dilute it by 50 you
know when I sell a machine to somebody I
want them to have a faith that I have
sold them the cleanest used washing
machine that they can possibly buy